THIS RIGHT HERE...
- YEAH.
- THIS GOES OUT
TO ALL OUR FALLEN HOMIES, YO.
COME ON.
- HEY, YO, REAL TALK.
- ALL RIGHT?
[liquid splashing]
- I MEAN,
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE A WASTE.
RIGHT?
DOES THAT MAKE ME A [bleep]?
OKAY, I'M A [bleep].
I'M SORRY.
I'M A BIG OL' [bleep].
- LET'S GO.
- I'M S--OKAY, HERE--
FOR OUR HOMIES.
- COME ON, MAN.
- POUR OUT YOUR DAMN BEER!
- OKAY, OKAY, FINE, FINE.
GLUG, GLUG, GLUG.
GLUG, GLUG, GLUG--
- NO, COME ON, MAN.
HEY, MAN, YOU GOT YOUR THUMB
IN THERE, MAN.
YOU NEED TO RESPECT
OUR HOMIES.
- JEEZ, OKAY.
OKAY, OKAY.
FOR THE HOMIES.
- WHA--
- [bleep], A TRASH BEER?
- WHAT? COME ON--
HEY, BEER IS BEER!
THE--JEEZ, I CANNOT WIN
ON THIS.
- WHAT?
- FINE.
I'M NOT ON BOARD WITH THIS,
BUT I'LL DO IT.
[liquid splashing]
- HEY, MAN,
WHAT YOU DOIN'?
- OH--OH, REALLY?
WHAT, THAT--THAT DON'T COUNT?
- AW, HEY, PUT THAT--
THAT'S NOT FOR--
AW, MAN.
- [sighs]
IT'S MORE OF A SYMBOL
THAN A GESTURE.
SOMEBODY BACK ME UP ON THAT.
RIGHT?
- HEY, MAN, THAT'S
DISRESPECTFUL RIGHT THERE.
YOU JUST DO IT.
- FINE.
FINE!
I'LL POUR IT OUT!
I'LL WASTE
THE DAMN BEER THEN!
[groans]
YOU KNOW, I-I'M J--
I'M JUST NOT A WASTER.
YOU KNOW, I SAVE EVERYTHING.
MAN, JAMAL KNOWS.
IF HE EAT A PIECE OF PIZZA
AND DON'T EAT THE CRUST,
I EAT THE CRUST.
- IF WE DO
A DRIVE-BY SHOOTING,
I WILL GO BACK
FOR THE SHELL CASES.
NOT TO HIDE
THE EVIDENCE,
BUT BECAUSE YOU
CAN RECYCLE THOSE.
THEY HAVE VALUE, MAN,
JUST LIKE THIS BEER.
I CAN'T WASTE NOTHIN',
Y'ALL.
IT'S PHYSICALLY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR ME TO WASTE THIS.
I CAN'T DO IT.
JAMAL, CAN YOU POUR IT OUT
FOR ME?
- OH, MAN.
COME ON, MAN.
- I MEAN, IT'S NOT
GONNA BRING 'EM BACK.
- STUPID.
- IT'S NOT
GONNA BRING 'EM BACK.